notre envoyé spécial elena volochine lé
combat anti un impact là vous vous
trouvez
alors en tout cas au niveau de la
frontière entre belgorod la région de
belgorod de la région de kharkiv on voit
énormément énormément de temps qu
d'artillerie de missiles acheminés vers
l'ukraine c'est vraiment un ballet
incessant
parce que cette frontière elle a été
prise d'assaut avant-hier elle a été
récupérée par les russes et donc du coup
et bien l'armée russe entre aussi par là
on a pas encore d'informations
exactement sur le niveau d'intensité et
le niveau d' avancée des russes en
territoire ukrainien mais oui on a
attendu toute la nuit effectivement à
les bombardements aussi dernières
informations ici à belgorod que je
voudrais vous donner et pour faire écho
à ce que disait clovis il disait qu'il y
avait une chasse aux agents russes avec
l'arrestation normalement de
l'arrestation notamment de leurs
collègues journalistes de notre côté
juste avant notre direct nos collègues
journalistes de médias russes
indépendants ont aussi été arrêté ici il
s'agit là des journalistes du journal
novaïa gazeta dont le directeur dmitri
mouratov a été nommé prix prix nobel de
la paix lors de la dernière de la
dernière édition du prix nobel et
d'autres journalistes du média
indépendant à radio svoboda qui lui a
été déclarée agents de l'étranger par
par le régime de vladimir poutine et
donc ces journalistes qui écrivent la
vérité sur ce qui se passe sur une
hauteur en ce moment en ukraine et bien
ils viennent d'être arrêtés on n'a pas
encore de nouvelles sur qu'est ce qu'on
leur reproche exactement mais ce qu'on
sait c'est que un petit peu plus tôt
l'état russe a exigé des médias russes
qu'il retire de leur publication toutes
les tous les articles qui portait le mot
guerre et aussi ceux qui relayait des
informations qui n'étaient pas de source
russe donc après après la propagande et
bien il ya maintenant la tentative
quasiment 2 d'interdire de museler les
médias indépendants
c'est un début de durcissement encore
plus s'il en fallait de d'atteinte à la
liberté d'expression en russie et on a
t'on il faudra qu'on qu'on voit jusqu'où
cela aussi va aller comment sont perçus
par la population russe les déclarations
mensongères du dj du dirigeant de leurs
dirigeants vladimir poutine
elles sont prises monaco pour argent
comptant depuis depuis maintenant sept
ans où vladimir poutine a réécrit cette
histoire à l'envers de la guerre en
ukraine disant que c'était l'ukraine qui
a attaqué ses propres populations
russophones dans le donbass disant que
l'ukraine et des tablettes en asie
disant que c'était l'otan qui
représentait la menace la plus directe
pour la russie et que la russie n'a
jamais attaqué personne mais ne faisait
que se défendre pour pour une raison qui
est vraiment très difficile à comprendre
de l'extérieur aujourd'hui de très
nombreux russes avec qui l'on parle
répète encore une fois malgré l'énormité
de la situation malgré le fait que leur
pays a attaqué le pays voisin il répète
que c'est l'ukraine qui est responsable
que soit c'est l'ukraine qui attaquent
la russie soit c'est ce qu'elle mérite
tout simplement c'est ramener à ramener
le bien par la force rétablir la
démocratie l'ordre laisser aux
ukrainiens le libre arbitre de leur
choix soit disant d'après la porte
parole du ministère russe des affaires
étrangères maria zara loba donc c'est
tout ce discours qui est pris pour
argent comptant par toute une partie de
la population en zombies fier par la
propagande une autre partie de la
population évidemment ne crois pas à ces
discours ne nous ne dit pas tout son
opinion mais vraiment les gens que l'on
interroge dans la rue et qui ont ce
discours de qui aurait un discours
pacifiste et de condamner les attaques
en ukraine ça fait trois jours qu'on est
là on a dû entendre une personne
merci beaucoup et léna volochine merci à
vous pour toutes vos informations